the main story right now Rob if you want
to pull this up we'll teet us off before
he comes in the main story everybody's
talking about right now is what just
happened with Russia okay Russia and
Wagner group Russia's putting orders
military to crush Wagner group grab
calls it treason now here's a few things
you need to know about what this is
number one
the guide behind Wagner group is a guy
named I want to pronounce this correctly
yevgeny progojin okay that's his name
Evgeni pregozian he's a billionaire it's
like the black water of Russia and this
guy's called his man to oust the
country's military leadership meaning
he's going directly against Putin's
military so we've got to oust the
military leadership and he claims the
war on Ukraine was based on false
pretense is they have roughly 25 000
soldiers okay these are a lot of uh
former ex Navy Seals you know these are
guys that are you know mercenaries these
are not regular types of these are
people that believe in the cause of
what's happening and not doing their job
because they have to do their job
they're doing their job because they
believe in what yevgeny is talking about
sometimes people like this are True
Believers you know 10 soldiers that are
true believers going against 100 that
are just doing their jobs sometimes the
10 has an edge over the other hundred
because they believe exactly what
they're doing so Robin Hood
exactly so Putin responded the actions
of Wagner group are seen as treason
there's a warrant out for him right now
uh they got bombed I think he claims
they got bombed uh their unit got bombed
they're bombing some you know gas pla
you know different kind of places that
they're taking out Putin is telling them
to get this guy here this guy being a
billionaire you know there's a lot of
stuff that's going on right now in
Russia do you have one that Clips around
to show on what's going on there I think
there's a uh uh whether it's Putin given
a speech or him giving a speech uh or
the explosion you know I think one of
the videos uh uh Vinnie you may have
given to him yeah see because Pat
they're advancing right now towards
they're saying like they're going
towards Moscow right now yeah he's
advancing through the streets and
there's a bunch of vehicles blown up and
they're on to the side and he's actually
advancing there right now what's this
your Rob
Lord of music just so we don't have to
is there any other thing to so this is
what this is them pulling up to who
well they took over a city called rostov
right and now they're basically marching
towards Moscow 25 000 soldiers a lot of
them actually recruited from prisons and
penal camps and they're they're
basically saying that this is the most
serious threat internally in Russia uh
essentially took over since a Civil War
in a country that has twice the nuclear
weapons we have and it's happening right
now
so Alex what are your thoughts on what's
going on right now in Russia obviously
it's a breaking story it's all over the
place on cover of every website this is
all they're talking about what do you
know about the story absolutely I'm glad
we just spent an hour and a half on me
but I was like let's not talk about me
because this I mean
what I really do study is geopolitics of
course you're a special ops guy I know
your history you're super smart I watch
your show all the time you know what
you're talking about so I'm really look
forward to me shutting up here what you
have to say because I'll be honest with
people I didn't talk about the submarine
until Friday because I wanted to see all
the pieces and they lied to us about
that they knew it blew up on Sunday they
use it as distraction bare minimum and
I'm sorry for the Dead uh and but on
this subject
um last night we're driving in here and
I'm seeing this news and I'm thinking
this is so dangerous this can't be real
and we were out to dinner late and I saw
it last night that it looked like it was
real but I just couldn't fathom it so I
spent a lot of time this morning
researching this is obviously very fast
moving but let me just tell listeners
and viewers I think you'll probably
agree with me in any other Mainline
military analysts would this is the most
dangerous development in modern history
with nuclear weapons okay uh ladies and
gentlemen Russia has tactical news in
intermediate range and long-range
weapons all over Western Russia their
submarines are off our Coast uh if you
know Russian history if a leader fails a
war they always kill them
um Putin is a soft liner compared to the
hardliners uh that are trying to take
control
and uh the I don't know who's working
with NATO I don't know if it is how do
you pronounce his name out of trouble um
evgeny yes what's this how do you say
his last name I was always butchered it
um the point is is that I'm having one
of those moments but it goes in this guy
bragovic yes yes pergovic from Santa
right pergovic I have trouble with
Russian and pregosian
see even those have a Russian agent I
don't know anything about this but
anyways pergocian I'm trying to draw the
data right now pagosian uh is is
obviously one of these billionaire
oligarchs that runs these catering
companies and he does a lot of psyops
with Putin is reportedly Putin's best
buddy and he's a former prisoner and all
the rest of it and he's a former friend
of Putin well well who's not saying he
wants to arrest him yes well you guys
have all the latest developments what
I'm saying is this
we know that NATO has back Channels with
the Russian Central Command and they're
both working to not have a nuclear war
behind the scenes so the question is is
it the Russian here's the different
scenarios I don't hear your take on it
is the Russian military
working with the West
is pregogin working with the last heads
up the Wagner group
or are neither of those sides really
working with NATO and this is really an
internal uh Power struggle and then the
other question is well will NATO back
one of the two
uh and then separately uh is this really
the Russian military that just bombed
pierogian and his troops they're going
to act like pergoian launches this
attack and then they're really going to
kill Putin and then say it was pregogin
this is this is this is serious Cloak
and Dagger fog of War I don't think
Putin really knows what's going on uh
because that's how Russia operates it's
total once the everybody works in unison
until the knives come out and right now
they're about all these different
factions all this stuff's going on and
the last time they moved the chairs
around in 1999 uh and Boris Yeltsin
disappeared you know we got we got Putin
uh so I don't think we know what we do
know is Russia is now under martial law
and uh Moscow is under martial law and
what 25 30 000 battle-hardened
ex-convict survivors of the sixty
thousands half of them died that were
sent to uh Ukraine who are credited with
winning most the battles uh because
pregogin says that the Central Command
is working with the west and losing on
purpose uh and that they're trying to
you know undermine things to take out
Putin and he says Putin needs to believe
him uh now they say he's trying to come
kill Putin so Putin we haven't seen him
say this but we see him in text say it
that that he's going to get pregogin uh
and so I don't think we know at this
point this this is unbelievably riveting
uh this just gives me unlimited
adrenaline I mean I'll guarantee you I'm
going to be scanning and reading and and
on and up I'm gonna do an emergency
broadcast today from from from uh the
pastor's place I've been here working
the whole time uh but I just absolutely
have to do this I'm glad we're here
covering it and now I'd like to hear all
the latest developments from you guys
and then see what you think Alex is this
one of those things where you're know
they say that the enemy of my my enemy
is my friend because this guy burgosian
the United States is issued an arrest
warrant for him in 2018. this has to do
with something something to do after the
2016 election I mean we can go there but
he's no friend of the states they have
an arrest warrant for him so I know that
you kind of alluded like what's the
NATO's involvement here what's going on
here is this an internal struggle you're
absolutely right there's definitely
you've set it up the internet there's
more questions than answers right now
but the average ongoing average American
is going to be like oh he's gonna put in
go get him people Americans that don't
know anything are going to be cheering
for this guy to to get Putin out they
have no idea what the hell they're
talking about you just you just brought
it to the key yep and that's why the
brainstorm first there's so many pieces
and then I come up with my answer the
bottom line is Putin is a middle of the
road guy compared to the hardliners
pregogin wants martial law and nuclear
war with the West he's completely
psychotic I've watched his videos where
he says it and he's Fearless too he's up
on the front lines for like a year and a
half the guy's a maniac and so I mean
Patrick what do you think I mean the
bottom line is the bottom line is Oh
yeah exactly let's cheer get rid of
Putin yeah then there'll be a whole new
power struggle and you'll get a much
more radical Russia what do you guys and
that's why Soros in the west were crazy
nine years ago to overthrow the
Ukrainian government and then run these
Ops against the Russians to get them to
come in just make no mistake I'm up for
the Russians either but the West started
this you're basically saying be careful
what you wish for you want Putin out of
there who's next in line
absolutely and for everybody that was
like Rush Trump and Russia and all the
Russia none of this would have been
happening if Trump was in so you're
absolutely congratulations for voting
for violence because this is what you
get Alex you're saying that this guy's
even more hard-line anti-west anti-nato
than Putin purgojin is is five times
worse than Putin really how do you know
that like what kind of research do you
pronouncing his name but I've been
studying them for 20 years I knew who
this guy was 20 years ago I mean I mean
I mean I've watched I mean he's he's
always been there he's been Putin's
right-hand man president before that I
mean they came up together in St
Petersburg uh and uh what can you tell
us about the the essence of the Wagner
group he heads this but what's the whole
purpose of these guys well let's let's
do this first and then that because
there's a key point I want to make here
or give me a pin all right I don't
remember to do it but if I don't forget
let me answer your question okay
thanks
um what is the Wagner group I'll do that
and then I'll do
um I forgot what I was gonna say was key
sorry
um that's how my brain works per gojin
you're asking what the Wagner group does
yes okay it was uh started uh 20 years
ago by Putin roughly uh as his own
private mercenary Army to kill people he
wanted killed inside Russia
with plausible deniability and then to
kill people around the world and to go
uh take over with mercenary forces uh in
the third world just like China and the
US doesn't take resources so they go
around a pillage uh and they uh also uh
assassinate people for Putin
and apparently they're currently in the
all over North Africa the Middle East
Syria they were the ones that helped
invade Crimea they're all over Ukraine
right now they're all over Ukraine
they've been one of the most divorces in
progojian has been saying the last year
and a half since it started
I know the weapon systems and he's
proven he's a good military commander
and I've got military guys you know he
got out of prison that's like Moses
force your military you're out and a lot
of these are you know former Special
Forces guys some of the best Russian
military they've got
and they're all saying the military is
losing on purpose we think they made a
deal with the west and they're going to
take out Putin he's been saying that for
a year uh and and so that's why I think
they may have tried to kill Putin and
blame pregogin because how does he think
with 25 000 troops if he can't take
Ukraine and he's only taken to some
cities how's he going to go take on the
Russia instead of got 10 times the force
Rob can you do me a favor just pull up
the WSU WS Chase story and let's just
read the whole thing so what what is
Wall Street Journal they just came out
they're fairly reasonable and in the
middle what's Wall Street Journal saying
let's just read this so
president Moon said Saturday he ordered
military to act against uh Wagner
parliamentary group that sees the
Russian stomach you've got that as
Wagner columns uh move forward towards
Moscow Saturday they were attacked by
Russian aircraft
in the vorage
region some 300 miles south of the
capital videos from the area show the
city main fuel Depot Ablaze a uh uh k-52
helicopter destroying a vehicle and
another helicopter narrowing the escape
in a Wagner anti-craft missile a Russian
plane was also shot down okay the crisis
unfolding in Russia represents the most
serious challenge to Putin's 20-year
23-year rule a direct consequence of the
strains put on Russia's society and
Armed Forces by the war that he
Unleashed against Ukraine in February of
last year if the Wagner group
Insurrection isn't put down swiftly The
Strife could significantly undermine
Russia's front-line troops in Ukraine
just as Kiev carries out a
western-backed offensive to Crime
occupied lands the uprisingly already
emerging Russia Society challenges
Putin's strategy of wagon a long war
against Ukraine okay so that's not
saying anything is saying
we're we we've withdrawn because our
half our troops died to uh you know the
western edge of Russia they began to
bomb us this morning we are not
advancing this is a lie and see notice
the footage they say they have is a fuel
Depots and their base is getting blown
up so the military sees them as a threat
and it's taking them out but here's the
larger question that was gonna please
continue but I want your take on this
notice the timing of this what happened
in the last two months the ukrainians
launched their counter offensive two
months ago not two weeks ago in probes
then they launched their main attack and
not hundreds but but like 400 or 500
I've watched the videos I spent days
searching and it's not duplicates the
Russians it takes three times the troops
and armor to take a position and you
know this for the military than it does
two two two two uh defend it so the
Russians got torn up going in but now
the ukrainians have got to go into their
defenses and so it got destroyed and
I've confirmed this from sources of the
military not just what was in the news
and even seeing in the midst okay the
offensive got destroyed most of the
equipment got destroyed uh like half of
it they've still got half the stuff the
West Senate they're sending more but
they don't have troops to operate it
because you got to train them and so the
Russians just destroyed this
counter-offensive then magically it
kicks into gear for a coup against Putin
that's the next phase if they can't
drive them out and have that Victory
then next week at Putin
and and so again is the high command
working with the West to get rid of
pergocian and Putin and set up their new
Russia system maybe with the West maybe
not we don't know which group this is
the timing of that fits with the West
with the Russian system cutting off
pagogian and Putin because these guys
are best friends now I'm not saying
that's what's happening but you know
Putin isn't sure and and so right now
he's like okay we're going to get
pregogin but I think Putin's main issue
is going to be his own military and his
own system or maybe he's killing his
best friend and does seem as a threat we
don't know but the Russian uh uh defense
just annihilated the ukrainians in the
last two months so why is this coming
now the West would normally go to this
next
but this is an overthrowing Saddam by
buying office generals this is Russia
and this is dangerous as hell and and
this is the same week too that we
accidentally sent them what 6.2 billion
dollars the Pentagon was like absolutely
whoops we sent uh Ukraine all this 200
billion's really been sent over the last
couple years and guaranteed half that's
coming right back to the global 100
so here here's obviously it's too early
to tell what's really going on but if
you think about it those who are for
Ukraine this is a beautiful thing
because what happens when it's shown
that the country is divided that's an
easy easy way to come in and capitalize
off this is horrible for Russia this is
horrible now the ukrainians you know are
going to launch the next counter
offensive because they only use after
four yeah now the Russians don't know
what the hell's going on Russian's gonna
have to withdraw some of the troops from
Ukraine to go fight this to fight in
Russia exactly so then who do you
think's really behind us it's the West
has the motive has the timing I'm not
saying it's that now but now we have 60
percent it's like a computer sixty
percent of the evidence with the mode of
the time in the history the background
How the West operates says it's the west
and as we get more data I'm not going to
like sit there and just get data that I
want to agree with if I get more data
showing that this is what's really
happening trying this and it's crazy
That's a classic Russian power play then
I'll go back to well now it's a 60
chance that it's as we're being told but
I'm just keep taking data and usually as
I take that data then as it's closer
it's almost always the analysis I have
and that's how real Intel stuff happens
so so what is the difference I mean this
you were saying happened to Yeltsin and
now you know they're on track for doing
it with him as well 23 years he's been
running it right we're talking about
since 2000 it's been Putin right and he
does look sick he really has thyroid
cancer yeah do you think so when you're
saying this could be you know
catastrophic
Etc et cetera from the nuclear
standpoint the bottom line with this is
this is super destabilization with the
number one nuclear power in a war zone
this is just on a scale of one to ten
the this is like a 9.8 I mean this is
because why because why because they've
got because because if he retaliates
because if Putin's like I'm sick of it
and I'm going to retaliate at or Ukraine
or why exactly they have Iran
Corporation threat ladder that's got 43
stages pull up the Rand Corporation 43
stages of escalation
and and this came up with this in the
60s and it still followed globally as
Doctrine the Russians adopted this as
well
and it's the stages of escalation
uh so it's the stages of military
escalation and there it is uh and and so
one of the reports they're always
updating it we're already at like staged
29. well when you get up you know and
any much more it's nuclear war it's
tactical then it's and it goes through
what both sides do and you've got a
dictator a strong man all this with
nuclear weapons all these forces
battling him all this craziness
one of Putin Falls what does the whole
thing disintegrates then where'd all the
nukes go or what's Ukraine going to do
and then other power groups Poland's
been talking about grabbing part of
Ukraine that was always part of them I
mean it's just like World War II once
this stuff starts it just gets out of
control the only difference is like for
for people that hear that and sometimes
they get you know Panic oh my God is
this going to lead to World War Three is
this the difference from my
understanding the difference between the
access Putin has to nuclear bombs versus
the way we have it he can't just press a
button and approve it there's got to be
multiple layers of approval that he has
versus the way we have it right
um
no no no that's not how it works okay if
you can pull up the nuclear protocol for
Russia it's a there is a different layer
of approval for him to choose to do
something like that look let's face it
from from in the last hundred years how
many times has the nuclear bomb been
dropped why shouldn't place okay yeah so
Hiroshima yeah but if a guy with dirty
bombs and like little suitcase bombs and
for a guy that is but the point dying
and a guy that's dying is pretty much it
looks like he's gonna they're attacking
the cap and about to take him over why
not just be like you know what I'm going
down I'm going down well here's Neil why
do you think he just gave nukes to
Belarus
that's his backup oh wow Rob is that it
it says here following the American
pattern the unlock and launch
authorization codes held by the general
staff at their command centers can be
sent directly to individual weapons
commanders who would execute the launch
procedures the crews on board doc
submarines have demonstrated the ability
to fire while surfaced at peer side
within 9 to 15 minutes after receiving
the order the other alternative the
general staff could direct uh could
direct missile launches directly from
command centers in the Moscow vicinity
or alternative facilities throughout the
country but it doesn't say that Putin
could directly the the way they have it
is which I which I think that's the
right way to do it I I don't think a
nuclear call should be I think it's
dangerous that Biden has that crazy man
that doesn't know who he is could like
just say watch the web I I think we all
know he doesn't have that I think you
know I don't even know if his button
works the other day he was putting his
hand on his chest
about working I was at a I was a flight
security controller at Malmstrom Air
Force Base Montana at a nuclear missile
base the there's two uh to launch a
nuclear weapon yeah there's so many
stages Pat and then it goes down to the
miscelliers who have to get
authenticated oh because let me tell you
what would happen if they did a nuclear
it would be it wouldn't be what happened
with Japan it would be so many people
involved it would be back and forth the
economy drops 50 you know the market
drops it so it's over too many people
are involved to not allow this from
happening and that's right of a tactical
weapon even issues the market dropped 50
yeah that's what the analysts believe
yeah but the point is I'm not trying to
be Luma Doom I'm just saying Russia with
the biggest nuclear Arsenal in a civil
war with a major war on its border we've
got a crazy president I'm just saying I
see all these pieces people better be
concerned no no and by the way there's
some rumors right now on Twitter talking
about the fact that you know Putin's
left Moscow I don't know if you saw that
or not Putin no he did leave yeah yeah
Putin left Moscow where did he head to
he's got an armored train that they're
not sure if the train left Alex you know
what would be interesting right now how
close did you follow the Doomsday Clock
very closely it's like 18 minutes to it
okay I'd like to see where that's at
right now it should have gone up I think
it was 18 minutes too last time I
checked that's the inter International
atomic energy uh Atomic scientists group
right how often do you do you check this
I'll check it I mean it's usually in the
news when it goes up so I see it you're
like watch this is my watch right here
yeah exactly I mean it was 18 minutes
too before uh let's see where it said
now it is a hundred seconds to midnight
apparently oh my gosh so I've never okay
okay okay they just changed it and I I
agree with that because it was 18
minutes they moved it from like 20
minutes to 18 and now it's now it's a
minute and a half or less
[Laughter]
what can the average person do to even
exclude that explain to the average
person what this means from 18 20
minutes to 18 minutes to 100 seconds to
midnight and back up to where it was in
1980 and 1990 so it just gives some
context right you'll have some images
yeah
it's two minutes to midnight so
basically the the clock is getting
closer and closer and closer closer
midnight means well it moves up and down
I go to 19 go to the early 1960s human
Missile Crisis
that was like they said was the worst uh
let me win this three minutes 12 minutes
so two minutes so three minutes to
midnight is 1949. Two Minutes to
Midnight this 1953.
uh does it go any further back or no Rob
that's it okay keep going up let's just
say go starting right after World War II
go keep going up keep going up so we got
seven minutes four minutes three minutes
six minutes nine minutes 14 minutes
seven minutes ten minutes seven minutes
five minutes six minutes five minutes
two minutes two minutes three minutes
three minutes keep going two minutes 100
seconds was 20 20 100 seconds 2021 it's
still the same thing 100 seconds 20 22.
so during covid and and does it have it
for today during covet
and now it's 100 seconds it's not
changed okay
I think that's some kind of article
There's an actual clock there's a press
release the point is that's their
feeling on it I I would just say this
moves the clock towards it
as Doom's clock moved check to see Rob
if they're doing Doomsday
well well let me ask you guys this
question
um
if they get rid of Putin and they put a
less hard-line guy in will that embolden
the warmongers in DC to launch more crap
because they want to go to war with
China and I don't like China and I don't
like Gigi ping uh it's just like the
Chinese people but I mean I hate the
Communist Chinese what they do and
everything but I mean they're really
trying to sell a war now with China this
is getting nuts
and if they are they're able to defeat
Russia by overthrowing Putin with a
bunch of intelligence operations I mean
this is just going to make them more
hungry so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
thank you
foreign